ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะคุณหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าว่าง
อันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 23
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตอะไรคะอีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 2  022 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้
วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
22 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนพฤษภาคำคมดีผชอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 24
ดีอะไรเนี่ย
พฤษภาคมปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะพี่ข้อ
2022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอน
นี้เวลา 11:00 น 11 โมงกี่นาที
สองนาที
11:02 น
พี่น้องเป็นตอนกลางวันนะคะๆวันสกรูฟ้า
โอเคไหมคะตื่นแล้วนะ
มันตื่น
แล้วค่ะเข้าไป
นาน
ตื่นหรือยัง
ตื่นแล้วค่ะนักเรียนเพราะว่า
11:00 นไงตื่น 7 กูฟ้าตื่นแล้วเอาครู
หญิงคิดว่า
ว่า
ผู้หญิงน่ะคิดว่าออกครูฟ้าเนี่ยดื่มกาแฟ
ดื่มกาแฟ
อเมริกาโน S เพรสโซ่ลาเต้คาบูชิโน่ผู้
หญิงคิดครูฟ้าดื่มกาแฟก็เลยตื่น
ครูฟ้าอ่ะไม่ได้ดื่มกาแฟประครูฟ้าตื่นตูม
มา
คุยฟ้าไม่ได้ดื่มกาแฟแต่ว่าครูฟ้าเมื่อ
ก่อนครูบาเพิ่งดื่มกาแฟไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าเคยดื่มกาแฟค่ะแล้วครูฟ้าจำได้ไหม
ครูฟ้าอันนี้ไม่ใช่ครูผู้หญิงแล้วนะเอา
เป็นรู้ข่าว
ครูบาสวยนะคะครูฟ้าแนทดื่มกาแฟอ่านครั้ง
แรกเลยนะครั้งแรกเขียนชื่อตัวเองนะคะ
มาดื่มกาแฟครั้งแรกครูฟ้า
อายุเท่าไหร่ครูฟ้าจำได้วงมั้ย
ดื่มกาแฟครั้งแรกอายุ
เท่าไหร่นะ
น่าจะ
4  22 ค่ะคู่หญิงครูฟายุ 22 แล้วครูฟ้า
อ่ะมาเขียนแล้วแล้วมีเจ็ดใหม่
2222 อายุมีควัน 222 ปีนะฮะครูฟ้าอายุ 22
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ยดื่มกาแฟครั้งแรกแล้ว
ผู้ฟ้างต่อมได้ไหมครูฟ้าดื่มกาแฟใส่ครู
ฟ้าดื่มกาแฟที่
กาแฟซื้อเซเว่นกูเซเว่นค่ะอ๋อ
อีกหรือว่ากาแฟกระป๋องไปกระป๋องให้ผู้
หญิงเพราะว่าตู้ที่ครูฟ้าก็คือกูก็คุยไม่
ได้เจอกันเห็นไหมนะอ้าว
อันนี้เป็นกาแฟนะคะกาแฟ
กาแฟกาแฟที่จะเห็นว่าจะต้องขยะอามานะห์
และผู้หญิง - ให้
มาขยับไม่ได้นะคะก็ยังไง
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าดื่มกาแฟที่เซเว่นอีเลฟเว่น
ต้องเรียนถึงเซเว่นแล้วเฮ็ดหาเห็นแล้วก็
เป็นกาแฟ
กระป๋องหน่อ
แล้วก็คือฟ้าก็ต้องเปิด
ใช่ก็เปิดดาแล้วก็ดื่มกาแฟกระป๋องเป็น
กาแฟ
เนสกาแฟหรอคะ you  say ไหมมันชื่ออะไร
กาแฟไหม S กาแฟมองเนสกาแฟมั้งผู้หญิง
ก็ไม่แน่ใจเหมือนกันนะคะว่าเป็นลา
เต้เอาเป็นกาแฟลาเต้กระป๋องที่เป็นกาแฟ
ที่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยดื่ม
ครั้งแรกใช่ไหมตอนอายุ 22 ปีที่ 122 นัก
เรียนกินผู้ช่วยอีกไม่เห็นนะ
22 กุมภาอายุ 22 ดื่มกาแฟครั้งแรกก็คือ
กาแฟลาเต้ของ Dead กาแฟนะคะเพราะผู้ฟ้า
ดื่มเซ็ตฟาก็ง่วงนอนเฮ้ย
โอเคนะคะกว่าก็นอนไม่โอเค
นอนก็ฮะนอน
กูฟังง่วงนอนดื่มกาแฟแล้วก็
นะ
New ทำไมดื่มทำไมแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยดื่มกาแฟ
กลากูฮะดื่มกาแฟครั้งแรกตอนอายุ 22 แล้ว
ก็หญิงผู้หญิงดื่มกราฟค่ะ
กาแฟครั้งแรกอายุเท่าไหร่
คุณครูหญิงดื่มกาแฟครั้งแรกอายุ
2-2 ขวบเพราะผิดค่ะอายุ 19
ซอยขวบดื่มกาแฟคุณพ่อคุณแม่ตี
ไม่ได้นะไม่ได้อายุ 19 ค่ะตอนแรกคุยคิด
อายุ 20 ไงมึงก็เลยเขียนเลข 2
ให้รู้สึก 19 แล้ว
ผู้หญิงดื่มกาแฟอะไรคะตอนอายุ 19 ผู้หญิง
คิดว่าครูหญิงดื่ม S เพรสโซ่เย็นนะคะเป็น
กาแฟเย็นนั่นแหละมีน้ำแข็ง
กาแฟแก้วประเทศนักเรียนเนี่ยจะไม่มี
เอสเพรสโซ่เย็นนะมีเอสเพรสโซ่เป็นช็อตแต่
ประเทศไทยและมี e&s เพรสโซ่เย็นผู้หญิง
ดื่มครั้งแรกนะถ้าจำไม่ผิดนะคะอร่อยไหม
อร่อยครูขอแนะดื่มแล้วตื่นคุยก็เลยดื่ม
กาแฟ
ผู้หญิงไม่ขมหรอเพราะว่ากาแฟเนี่ยขมใช่
ไหมเรียนให้แฟน
กาแฟมันขมมีน้ำตาลน้ำตาลน้ำตาลน้ำตาลน้ำ
ตาลน้ำตาลเทียบ
บ้านเยอะจังเลยมีน้ำตาลมากๆก็เลยไม่สมนะ
กูบาสครูหญิงมีคำถามเกี่ยวกับครั้งแรกอีก
นอกจากดื่มกาแฟมีอะไร
นี่กูยิ่งว่าอะไรคะครูฟ้า
พัดลมเฮ้ยอ้าว
ไม่ใช่พัดลมเหรอไม่ใช่กูมาดูดีๆ
อ๋ออ๋อจ้าก็จะยานตักรยานผู้หญิงสถานภูฟ้า
ว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยขี่จักรยานครั้งแรกครูมัด
จำได้ไหมว่าครูฟ้าอ่าอายุเท่าไหร่อันนี้
ไฟฟ้าใช้กะลูกค้านะคะ
ทำได้ค่ะกูหญิงครูฟ้าอายุเท่าไหร่
น่าจะ
อายุ
อะ 5 ขวบ
สาวๆประมาณนี้ได้อ่าโอเคหาครัวก๊อกหน้า
จักรยานเนี่ยเป็นจักรยานเล็กๆๆใช่ไหม
จักรยานเล็กๆแล้วก็มีอันนี้ก็คือล้อ
กี่ล้อ
3 ล้อ 4 ไหม 3 ไม่เอากูฟ้าเพียงที่ข้าง
เดียวหรอว่า
มันเป็นหนึ่งสองสามเยาะๆเข้าใจแล้วโอเค
โอเคโอเค
2  3  Oz จักรยาน 3 ล้อ
พยานฝากมีสามล้อ
สามร้อยนะคะ 306
เหมือนครูหญิงครูหญิงเนี่ยขี่จักรยาน
ครั้งแรกก็
อายุ 5 ขวบเหมือนกันจริงหรอหรอผู้หญิง
ปั่นจักรยานสับขี่จักรยาน 3 ล้อไหมวิ่ง 4
ร้องไงมันก็เลยถามฟาร์มอ่ะผู้หญิงก็มี
หนึ่งใช่ไหมคะรอที่ 1 รอที่ 2 แล้วก็จะมี
รออันนี้ก็จะมีไปทางนี้ใช่ไหม
เด็กล้ออันนี้ 3 แล้วก็สี่มีขี่จักรยาน 4
ล้อกูแล้วแก้ปวดโอเก่งก็ถอดได้ไงกูฟ้าไม่
มีแล้วก็ไม่มีไม่มีก็เหลือจักรยาน 2 ล้อ
เก่งมากค่ะครูหญิงผู้หญิงพยานล้มไหมคะไม่
หลงค่ะ 4 หรอลูกค้าครูฟ้าขี่จักรยานใช่
ไหมพอมีจักรยานเนี่ยหนึ่งร้อน 2 ล้อแล้ว
พอเราขี่แล้วเนี่ยเหมือนครูฟ้าพูดจักรยาน
ล้ม
จักรยานล้มครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่าครูฟ้าขี่
จักรยานแล้วจักรยานล้มล้มแบบ Oil เจ็บ
เจ็บ
ครั้งแรกเนี่ยครั้งแรก
ครูฟ้า
อายุเท่าไหร่
จักรยานลงโง่นะคะอันนี้เนาะจักรยานล้มอีก
ครั้งแรก
ใต้ที่แบบมีสองล้อนะมีจักรยาน 100 แล้วก็
2 ล้อไม่ไม่เอาสามล้อเราโตแล้ว
น่าจะประมาณ
สิบขวบมั้ง
สิบขวบให้สําพยานฟ้าขี่จักรยานเท่านั้น
ขี่จักรยานเร็วๆว่าชอบเร็วๆนะคะ 100
กิโลเมตรอิศรญาณแบบนี้ต่อชั่วโมง
เร็วๆ
ที่จักรยานเร็วๆ
100 กิโลเมตรต่อชั่วโมง
แล้วครูบาก็เลยล้ม
โอ้ย
มีฟ้าร้องไห้ไว้
ร้องไห้อ๋อ
ก็ไม่ร้องไห้เจ็บเจ็บดีมากเป็นเจ็บนะเจ็บ
โอ๊ยเป็นสีแดงๆสีแดงเต็มคุยหนิงน่ะประมาณ
สิบแล้วครูหญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงเนี่ยขี่
จักรยานแล้วจักรยานล้ม
อายุเท่าไหร่
อายุสิบขวบเหมือนกันผู้หญิงก็ 10 ไส้แต่
ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ได้ขี่เร็วๆเหมือนรูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงขี่จักรยานใช่ไหมคะเคารพตัวเองได้
ไหมคะ
ตัวเองที่ไหนครับ
ไม่ได้นักเรียนนี่เนี่ยจากบ้านนะคะ
บ้านแล้วก็ไปโรงเรียน
แต่ไปโรงเรียนเนี่ยขี่จักรยานแล้วถนนถนน
น่ะมันไม่อาเจ้
เขียนแบบจักรยานจักรยานครูหญิงเนี่ย
จักรยานเนาะ
จักรยานเนี่ยสูงแต่กูหญิงเนี่ยตัวเล็ก
เวลากูหญิงอีกอยู่อย่างเงี้ยภูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงหน้ากูไม่ได้เพราะจักรยานมันสูงไง
ใช่แล้วถนนในวันนี้หินอย่างเงี้ยอะไอ้เรา
ก็ปั่นแล้วก็เลยล้มแล้วก็โอเคเจ็บหัวเข่า
อันนี้เป็นเท้าเราใช่ไหมคะแล้วตรงเนี้ย
หัวเข่าโอ๊ยเจ็บนะแต่ก็ไม่ร้องไห้ไม่ร้อง
ไห้นะแต่จักรยานล้มครั้งแรกก็อายุสิบขวบ
ทำไมอ่ะกูเพราะว่าเลือด
แต่พอเราตกขึ้นโตขึ้นเราก็ไม่ขี่จักรยาน
คะแล้วเราก็มอเตอร์ไซค์รู้
ครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่าดีมากค่ะผู้หญิงไม่อยาก
วาดนะฮะก่อนก็แล้วกันนะครูหญิงนะคะผู้
หญิงคันอะไรคะขับคำมอเตอร์ไซค์
ได้ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์
ครั้งแรกแต่นะคะครูหญิงอายุ
16 ปีนะ
ถ้าครูหญิงจำคิดว่า 16 อ่ะเออผู้หญิงโต
แล้ว
ผู้หญิงอายุ 16 ปีก็ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์
ครั้งแรกก็ที่กูฟ้าวาดนะคะมอเตอร์ไซค์
แล้วครูฟ้าล่ะคะครูฟ้าขับมอเตอร์ไซค์
ครั้งแรกครูฟ้าอายุเท่าไหร่
ฟ้าขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ครั้งแรกมี
อายุ
2 ขวบให้เฮาหญิง
อายุ 19
โตกว่าครูหญิงอีกแล้วๆเพราะกูฟ้าเนี่ยไป
เรียนใช่มั้ย University นะคะอะไรเนี่ย
เรียน University ใช่ไหม
ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์จากบ้านไปเรียนเหรอคะไม่
ใช่ฮะจะอพาร์ทเม้นท์ค่ะคอนโดออกเรียน
ก็ต้องขับมอเตอร์ไซค์ครั้งแรกนะคะคิดเอง
ขับเองกูทำเองไม่มีใครบอกให้หาขับเองเลย
มา 100 กิโลเมตรต่อชั่วโมงชั่วโมงเหมือน
เดิมนะคะครูฟ้าไปเรียนใช่ไหมไปเรียนแล้ว
พอเรียนขอจบเนาะเราอายุ
อายุ 10  19 ใช่ไหม 20  21 แล้วก็ 22
เพราะอายุ 22 และก็เรียนจบ
ขอบเหรียญศพแล้วก็ต้องทำงานใช้ไปออฟฟิศทำ
งานหรือว่าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่าครูป๊า
ทำงานครั้งแรก
อายุเท่าไหร่
ครูฟ้าทำงานครั้งแรกอายุ
22 ผู้ทำงานอะไรทำงานเป็นถั่วฟ้านะคะ
ทำงานเป็นผู้ฟ้า
เป็นดาราเหรอทีวีหรอคะ tv  show เหรอคะ
ลูกค้าทำงานอะไรคะอ่ะเมียครูเนี่ยฮะขอครู
สอนภาษาไทยเขาที่ aua ไออ่ะสอนภาษาไทยพี่
aua  US กูพาทำงานครั้งแรกเลยหรอครั้ง
แรกเลยหาที่ aua  on อายุ 22 ก็ไปทำงานจะ
อยู่อีกนะฮะ
ตื่น Aun
ผู้หญิง Heart ผู้หญิงทำงานครั้งแรกอายุ
เท่าไหร่หูคุยทำงานครั้งแรกเนี่ยจะอายุ
อยู่ทำงานก็คือเด็กๆอ่ะเวลาโรงเรียนปิด
เทอมสมัยไม่ต้องไปโรงเรียนคิดว่าผู้หญิง
ทำงานครั้งแรกนะจะอายุ
สิบขวบ
โหอ่ะๆๆก็จะ 11 นดีใจมากเกินไปไหมใช่ค่ะ
จะประมาณ 11 ขวบอันนี้บ้านครูหญิงใช่ไหม
คะอ่าแล้วก็ใกล้ๆบ้านเนี่ยมีฟาร์ม
มีความใช่ไหมปลูก
จะปลูกข้าวโพดอะไรเงี้ยเป็นฟาร์มหญิงก็
ไม่ได้ไปโรงเรียนใช่ไหมเดือนเมษายน
พฤษภาก็ไปทำงาน
ที่นี่นี่หนา 8 ไม่ใช่สิ 6  7  7  8  9
10  11
13  14  15  16  17  9 ชั่วโมง
100 บาทนะนักเรียนอยู่ที่อายุ 11 คู่ว่า
เอ้าช่วง 100 บาท 8 สนุกไงก็มีครูหญิงมี
เพื่อนมีเพื่อนมีเพื่อนเยอะๆทำงานครั้ง
แรกจริงๆ
โอ้โหนก็จะทำไงงานออฟฟิศใช่ไหมเป็นออฟฟิศ
จริงๆแล้วก็ต้องไปไปไปทุกวันแล้วก็คิดว่า
ผู้หญิงอายุ
19 ค่ะครูฟ้า
19 เป็น Shop ร้านถ่ายรูปสวยมีช็อปแล้ว
ก็ถ่ายรูปและทำงานแบบต้องไปท่าตอนอายุ 11
ขวบที่ฟาร์มและคุยกับ 5 ไม่ไปโอเคไม่เป็น
ไรนะคะก็เป็นการทำงานครั้งแรกนะคะของเรา
แล้วไม่รู้ว่าของนักเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยทำ
งานครั้งแรกตอนอายุเท่าไหร่
จักรยานชำแรกนะคะครีมมอเตอร์ไซค์ครั้งแรก
อายุเท่าไหร่ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เนาะแต่
ว่าวีดีโอนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะเดี๋ยวเรา
เจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าโทรหาสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ